Speaker 1: Let's go to Justin from Utah. Justin
from Utah. You know, most of our Utah callers just
happen to be Mormons, even though I know Utah
is filled with people who aren't Mormons. And
oftentimes, Utah callers are very interesting.
Welcome, Justin. What can I do for you.
Speaker 2: David? Yeah. So I was born LDS. I am
no longer Elvis. Just. Just for the record. Okay.
Yeah. Obviously, I live in a in
a very red state with regard to,
you know, the gun control debate and so on. I
often hear that, you know, we need more we need
more heroes. Right. Versus stricter gun control.
I liken that to if we were able to stop cancer,
no one ever suffers from the disease again.
Right. By that logic, the best solution is to,
you know, instead hire more doctors
rather than actually cure cancer. Right.
Speaker 1: I think that's a very interesting
analogy, which is rather than more good guys
with guns to fire back at the bad guys with guns.
But make clear by the time the police get there
that they're the good guy, not the bad guys of
the police shouldn't shoot them. Why don't we just
try to reduce the number of shootings that even
start to begin with? I think it's an apt analogy.
Speaker 2: Tasting.
Speaker 1: Anything else today, Justin?
Speaker 2: No, I just, you know, I see that
online all the time. You know, it's a common
talking point. You know, arming teachers,
it just it's ridiculous. I don't understand
where the disconnect is on on that other side.
Speaker 1: Do you do you have kids, Justin?
I do. Would you? I mean, I don't
know what kind of school they go to,
but if a school they went to armed teachers,
would you pull them from the school?
Speaker 2: I would consider it silly.
Speaker 1: I mean, a lot of times with
these things, it's like easier said than done, you
know? The logistics can be complicated and then
you've got to move. Kids who have an established
social group like I'm not pretending it's easy,
but it's at least something you would think about.
Speaker 2: Yeah, absolutely. I would have
the means to homeschool if I. If I
wanted to. Right. Yeah. You know,
it's. Yeah. It's very troubling, though.
Speaker 1: Out of curiosity, you said you're
like former LDS. Are you no longer a believer
in the doctrine or you are no longer part of
an organized LDS church, but you're still
sort of like a believer of the doctrine?
Speaker 2: I am not a believer in any organized
religion. Okay. The. Interestingly, you know,
my my mother would not go to church. She would
drop us off. Oh, is that right? Yeah. Be at the
end of you know, as we got older, we would
walk in one door, go out the other, and go
hang out for a while. Okay. That's interesting.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend would listen.
Great to hear from you. Appreciate
your insights and your question.
All right. There is Justin from Utah.
Very, very interesting to hear from you